alex is with us in new york city hi alex
welcome to the ramsey show
hey dude how are you doing better than i
deserve what's up
uh just a little background i graduated
college or something i found a full-time
job going and um i just want to i have
minimal liabilities
the work from home situation and i want
to invest aggressively
as early as i can and i'm interested in
investing in rental property but as you
know
real estate in this region is you know
astronomical so
i was looking into um out of state
markets where
you know my money would be served and
you know i have a better opportunity to
pay all cash for these rentals and i
just kind of want to get your thoughts
on that
what do you uh 70 thousand
how old are you 22
okay and so how much do you have saved
uh i'm about 40 000 save right now i
hope this student wants that like i i
definitely plan to
pay those off of the check like very
very soon so
it's about ten thousand students you
live in manhattan
uh i live in new york area not not in
the uh
where do you live um
i live in staten island okay all right
cool
all right i'm just trying to figure out
how he was making it on 70 grand dude
i mean i kind of know that market um
so it's a good income but it's a very
expensive place to live as you know even
staten island but
nowhere near like manhattan so all right
hey um
no look here's the problem
and i own a bunch of real estate as you
probably know alex and i love real
estate as you probably know
and i've had really bad experiences
without a with rental properties that i
cannot lay my hands on
i need to be able to drive by them look
at them and even if someone else
is running them for me i i you just make
better decisions if they're within
you know shooting distance here where
you can get to them um
it just sets you up for a problem and if
if you have a rental property that goes
bad it could set you back more
than then three of them going good
could set you forward and so that's the
problem i
you know real estate requires it's got a
hassle factor to it as an investment
it requires involvement and i know you
cannot just stand back and watch someone
else run it and it all work out
uh it just i mean you can have a
property manager and there are
some good property managers but no one
manages your stuff like you do so you've
got to look over the shoulder of the
property manager to be sure that things
are being done right and go
how much did we pay for that hot water
eater say what
you know that kind of stuff and you
gotta have you know and when that's
three four hours away from you or eight
hours away from you or something
that just becomes very tenuous and it
sets you up for a high potential to have
a bad experience in real estate rather
than a good one
so i would tell you not to do that i
would tell you instead let's just pile
up our money
and and let's see where your career
takes you and see where you end up
landing
and let's just start invest i would just
use mutual funds at your age to begin to
build it up you don't have enough to buy
it anyway today so it doesn't matter
it's all theory at this